okay I want to take a moment to let each
of you think to yourselves about the
last time you sent or received a fax
well for me it was this morning because
one piece of my work is making sure that
everyone in the US has the information
that they need to make decisions about
the candidates on their ballot and
collecting that information from the
local government offices responsible for
maintaining it means sending and
receiving a lot of faxes voting is one
of our most fundamental rights it's one
of the most tangible ways that each and
every one of us can shape our
communities and as we enter this fourth
Industrial Revolution where technology
is changing everything around us you
would think but something as important
as the right to vote that we would have
the most modern secure inclusive system
that could exist but we don't when we
look at comparable democracies the US
has one of the lowest voter turnout
rates in the world we have a system
where even the most persistent voters
come up against exhausting barriers a
system where 20th century technology
like fax machines and outdated practices
stand in the way of full vibrant
participation in u.s. presidential
elections turnout hovers around 60%
the numbers are even lower for local
elections that means that nearly 40% of
Americans aren't voters that's nearly a
hundred million people I believe in
something very straightforward that
everyone should have the information
that they need to become a voter that
the voting process should be seamless
and secure and that every voter should
have information they trust to make
decisions about the candidates on their
ballot because when more people vote
together we make better decisions for
our communities
so I've spent the last eight years on a
mission to push our democracy into the
21st century now one of the most common
approaches to election modernization is
advocating for policy change and that's
an incredibly important piece of the
strategy for building the system where
millions more people become voters but
I've taken a different approach I have
focused on a critical yet largely
untapped resource for election
modernization local election officials I
work with thousands of local election
officials across the country to build
tools and skills that they can use
immediately to transform the way that
they're engaging today's voters folks
like Kat Murray Kat Murray have worked
together for years in a windowless
office in the basement of the Mercer
County Courthouse in West Virginia
together they have a tremendous
responsibility their local election
officials serving Mercer County's 40,000
registered voters local election
officials are the public servants that
do the day-to-day work that makes our
election system function when you fill
out a voter registration form they're
the folks that process them and add you
to the rolls
they're the folks who buy the technology
that we use to cast and count ballots
they recruit and train the volunteers at
your local polling place and they're the
official nonpartisan source for
informing people in their communities
about how to vote and unlike other
countries where there's some form of
centralized election authority in the
u.s. there are seven thousand eight
hundred and ninety seven different
county and municipal offices like Katt
Murray's that each have an independent
role in administering elections yes
that's nearly 8,000 slightly different
ways that you might experience voting
based on where you happen to live when I
was talking with Katt and Murray like so
many election officials that I talk with
in rural towns and in major cities alike
they're deeply proud of getting to help
people in their communities but they're
also worried all of the new tools that
people were using to get information the
internet social media
they were difficult to figure out how to
use effectively and they felt like they
weren't fully meeting the needs of
Mercer County voters one thing that they
really wish that they had was a website
so they could create a hub with
information about how to register and
upcoming elections and a place to put
election results see at the time when
voters had questions they had to either
call or visit their office which meant
that cat Murray were inevitably
answering the same questions over and
over again which was both a super
inefficient use of their time but also
created totally unnecessary barriers for
voters when that information could just
live online in Mercer County wasn't
alone at the time there are one of 966
counties in the u.s. that had no voting
information online I'll let that sink in
they were one of the nearly one-third of
counties in the US that had no place
online to find official information
about how to vote the cat Murray not
having an election website was
unacceptable but they didn't have very
many options they didn't have the budget
to hire a web developer they didn't have
the expertise to build a site themselves
so they went without and 40,000 voters
and Mercer County went without we're in
a moment where we have an unprecedented
opportunity to transform civic
engagement technology is revolutionized
in science and industry it's already
transformed how we connect with one
another and understand the world around
us but our democratic institutions
they're being left behind the u.s. is
one of the few major democracies in the
world that puts the onus of voter
registration on the individual voter
rather than the government the rules
that govern how to vote vary from state
to state and sometimes even County to
County and we have ballots that are
pages and pages long this November on my
ballot there are literally over 100
different people and referenda for me to
make decisions about we have to be using
the best tools we can bring to bear to
help voters navigate this complexity
now or not one of the most common
narratives I hear in my work is that
people aren't civically engaged because
they're apathetic because they don't
care but as my brilliant friends at the
Center for civic design say if there is
a 'kathy it comes from the system not
the voter we can change the system right
now by connecting local election
officials like Katt Murray with 21st
century tools and the training that they
need to use them to better serve voters
tools and training to do things like use
social media for voter engagement or use
data to staff and equip polling places
so that we don't see hours long lines at
the polls or training on cybersecurity
best practices so that we can ensure
that our voting systems are secure when
we invest in this approach we see
meaningful lasting results Katt Murray
are online now inspired by their
experience we built a website template
using research-based best practices in
civic design and developed a training so
that Kat Murray are able to maintain
their site themselves in less than a
week they went from having never seen
the back end of a website to building a
resource for Mercer County voters that
they've been independently keeping up to
date since 2014
today the 40,000 voters in Mercer County
and over a hundred thousand voters and
counties across the country have
everything that they need to become a
voter directly from their local election
official on a mobile-friendly
easy-to-use
accessible website and we can even
further scale the impact when local
election officials are not only reaching
out through their own channels but
they're extending their reach by working
in partnership with others efforts like
the ballot information project and the
voting information project work with
election officials nationwide to create
a centralized standard database of key
voting information like what's on your
ballot and where to vote that
information powers tools built by
companies like
Google and Facebook to get information
in the places where people already are
like their newsfeed and search in 2016
the ballot information project connected
the public with information about
candidates and referenda over 200
million times
helping between a third and a half of
every single person who cast a ballot
and that model has been replicated for
elections around the world when we look
at efforts in other areas of government
we can see the opportunity when we
listen to the public's needs and we meet
them with modern tools I think about my
friends at M relief who have helped
260,000 families unlock 42 million
dollars in food benefits by helping
government agencies transition away from
a 20-page paper based application for
food stamps - a process that can happen
in ten questions over text message in
fewer than three minutes that kind of
transformation is possible and voting
it's happening right now
but there's still so much work to do now
if you have any technical boon in your
body
I know you're thinking this is all
solvable the technology that we need
exists we collectively have the
expertise you might even be thinking
about volunteering at your local
election office I love how
solutions-oriented you are but to be
clear the work that is needed to
modernize our election system isn't
something that's going to happen using
20% time or through a hackathon or by
doing a one-off technology project what
we need is significant sustained
long-term investment investment in
technology and investment in the skills
of local election officials to run 21st
century elections because if we don't
invest in the long game we risk finding
ourselves perpetually behind so if
you're ready to help millions
if you're ready to close the gap between
the system that we have and the system
that we deserve we need you
organizations that are doing this work
year-round need you local election
offices need you come join us thank you
[Applause]